this week CBS News polling put president
Trump's approval numbers at 41% as he
hits the 100 day mark that's lower than
his predecessors were at this point in
their administration's CBS News
elections director Anthony salvano helps
us dig a little deeper into the results
he joins us from our Washington bureau
Anthony good morning good morning how
are you how deep is the partisan divide
on this anthony it's very deep anthony
and it's actually as deep as we have
ever seen what you see in these numbers
is that his low overall approval rating
underneath that you've got very strong
support from republicans from his base
who very much like what he's doing but
across the divide you see democrats
giving him historically low approval
numbers typically we see the op the
opposing party giving a president at
this point maybe a third support that's
not huge but it's something but
democrats today are giving him just ten
percent support so that's a political
story too you still got this other half
of the country who says that they feel
like they're still waiting for him to
reach out Anthony how much does the
president's base care about him keeping
promises on signature proposals like
building a wall with Mexico or repealing
and replacing the Affordable Care Act
well we see similar divides on these
policies Alex where when you ask people
if they like the idea of building the
wall or of the travel ban a majority say
that they do not however that Republican
base does and then when you follow up
and you say to them well do you think
that President Trump is making progress
on these things that you want they say
yes that they think he is so for that
base they see a president who is keeping
his promises and delivering though they
also understand that it's part of a
process that things don't necessarily
happen overnight which is why you also
see people saying well is a hundred days
enough time to judge many people say
well no it's it's not enough time the
president outlines a new tax plan this
week Anthony how confident are Americans
about this well actually most folks
think that their taxes will go up as
opposed to going down there's two things
about this one is that we started asking
people before he had rolled out some of
that plan
and so as details come out you might
expect those numbers to change the other
part anthony is that little polling
secret whenever you ask people about
what's going to happen with their taxes
they're pretty cynical I usually say
they think they're going to go up and
that's kind of universe they've learned
a lesson that's why but Anthony will
there be punitive results if people's
taxes go up I mean will that shake the
the core support he has among his base
well that's a that's a great question
because we see throughout these these
polls that where people evaluate this
president as with others is going to be
transactional it's going to be about
what happens in their own lives some of
these larger picture issues is America
winning well Republicans think that
America is winning now but at the core
of this is going to be whether or not he
delivers and changes people and changes
what people are seeing in their lives
and very specifically on the economy
that was one of the things that really
underpinned his win last November and
taxes and how much money you pay out of
your pocket could certainly go straight
to that Anthony quickly how much
confidence do Americans have in the
president's handling of North Korea
there's more unease than there is
confidence but having said that they see
North Korea as a threat the difference
is that Americans say they think it's a
threat that can be contained and doesn't
necessarily warrant military action
right now Anthony Anthony salvano the
man with the number is always good to
talk to you thanks Anthony
thank you